thank you so much for having me so my
name is Lara Acton I am a social
psychologist at Simon Fraser University
and today I'd like to tell you what some
of the work I've been doing for the past
eight years or so looking at whether
giving feels good so by way of an
introduction I thought I'd do a quick
identity check test does anybody know
who this man is I strongly suspect most
of you do but just show hands anybody
want to say it out loud
we're in Buffett that's right and as I'm
sure many of you if not all of you are
very well aware that Warren Buffett
recently wrote and has been pushing this
idea of the 99% pledge encouraging many
other millionaires wealthy folks to
consider giving away a large chunk of
their earnings before their passing and
what I wanted to draw your attention to
was not the fact that he did it which i
think is really interesting in fact
maybe I should articulate the explicit
change of topic so Patrick was talking
about what leads people to give I'm
gonna be talking about the consequences
of how people feel after they give and
so maybe that's an interesting point
it's not I think it's fascinating that
Warren Buffett chose to do this but what
I wanted to draw your attention toward
was how he reported feeling afterward
was that he couldn't be happier with
this decision
and so I wanted to talk to you guys
about today is really how Warren Buffett
might not be so unique in his experience
of joy when giving I'm in fact I wanted
to tell you about some my work that
suggests that giving makes people feel
good and this is work that started here
in North America actually in Vancouver
but then built outwards and has since
been looking at this finding in rich and
poor countries in some of our youngest
givers children under the age of two and
actually an ongoing project I'm working
on right now with one of my graduate
students looking at whether giving feels
good not only and perhaps some of our
more predictable samples where people
have financial resources to give away
but even in folks who may be showing
behavioral dispositions to suggest they
might not be all that concerned about
others all right so we'll start from the
top and in our 15 minutes or so together
I'll try to walk you through these
findings so this work started when I was
at UBC doing my graduate work while
working with Elizabeth Dunne and Mike
Norton at Harvard Business School and we
wanted to examine whether spending money
generously or what we called pro-social
spending might have these emotional
benefits
and to begin addressing this question we
started by asking a nationally
representative panel of Americans how
much money they spend in a typical month
on for spending categories so the first
to where their bills and expenses their
second was the second category was gifts
for their selves themselves the third
was gifts for others and the fourth was
donations to charity people didn't seem
to have any trouble reporting how much
they spend in a typical month on these
four categories but then what we did was
just a simple bit of math and translated
these four spending categories into to
spending indices the first was what we
called an index of personal spending
just how much people spent in an average
month on themselves the second was an
index of what we called pro-social
spending or spending money on others as
opposed to oneself so kind of a crude
measurement in our initial studies but
we thought a good first pass at trying
to understand how much fun money people
spend in a month on these two categories
and then going one step further
addressing what we thought would be of
particular interest was how these two
spending indices relate to well-being so
we simply asked folk in general how
happy are you these days on a five-point
scale so then what we did was we put
these two spending indices into an
equation simply predicting how happy
these folks were and what we found was
that how much money people spend on
themselves was actually surprisingly not
related to their happiness but how much
money they spent on others was in fact a
strong predictor such that the more
money people spent on others in an
average month the happier they reported
being and importantly oops I'm sorry I
guess they don't have a note for this on
here but importantly this held even when
we controlled for income so it wasn't
just that wealthier folks had more money
to give away and were therefore happier
and happier wealthier people do
typically report higher levels of
happiness but this seemed to be a
separate and independent effect such the
people who were more generous reported
higher levels of happiness but I I'm
really glad with the question Patrick
got last because I think that's a really
important question here about the
direction of causality which is is it
being generous that makes people happy
or happier people who are more generous
or really something and another third
variable as we call it in psychology
that's driving this relationship and to
be honest with this one study we
actually couldn't address that question
which is why we went further and
conducted some experiments and so
and probably the highlight of my
graduate school career I got to go out
on the University of British Columbia
campus and recruit as a bunch of
undergrad students to take part in a
study on everyday spending habits and if
they agreed I recruited them in the
morning hours on campus gave them either
five or twenty dollars to spend which is
a huge deal to undergrads by the way and
I didn't give them any spending
directions the only thing I asked them
to do was to spend it in line with one
of these two broad spending categories
so the first was either a way that was
consistent if you will with this
personal spending category so on a bill
expense or gift for yourself or the
second category which was a gift for
someone else or a donation to charity
now note that people didn't get to
choose which way they got to spend it we
randomly assign them to condition so
it's not that happier folks could
gravitate towards this less happy folks
could gravitate towards this we told
them how to spend it so we could measure
the causal impact of these spending
guidelines if you will at the end of the
day so what did we find
well we found simply put the people who
were randomly assigned to spend money on
others were significantly happier at the
end of the day we asked everybody to
spend the money by 5:00 p.m. so that a
research assistant who didn't know how
they were told to spend the money could
call them find out how they were feeling
and the folks who received either five
or twenty dollars it actually didn't
matter how much money they got it was
how they were told to spend it so people
who spend generously were happier at the
end of the day so after this original
work was conducted and published we
received a bunch of questions asking who
the people were really luckily really
interested in this work which was very
exciting it wasn't just my mom which is
normally the case so but some of the
most burning questions we got it was
whether this is unique unique to North
America where on average I mean not your
typical undergrad population but on
average people have extra disposable
income to use in an average month or
whether is these warm glow benefits if
you will of generous spending might be
detectable in other places where people
have more limited financial resources
and less money to spend on others
because it's certainly possible you can
imagine that you know in living in a
third world country perhaps where you
don't have much money to spend when you
do have money you you prefer to spend it
on yourself but not only that you get
the greatest emotional rewards from
doing so because you have to pay your
monthly bills it's
so what we did was we tried to collect
some data from relatively rich in
relatively poor countries to really see
if this finding was could be detected
beyond our North American sample of
students and average Americans so what
we did was I with a psychologist at at
several places but the main one I'll
tell you about here was with a her name
is Justine burns at the University of
Cape Town in South Africa and what we
did was we strategically tried to
recruit participants of low income in
South Africa and UBC students who are
not necessarily low income but we
brought them into the lab they were told
that they were gonna be taking part in
about a 25-minute experiment and after
filling out some initial questionnaires
everybody was told that in addition to
their study payment that they had been
promised and and provided they had
earned an additional few dollars that
they could use to purchase a goodie bag
filled with treats this goodie bag
filled with treats they could feel as
they liked so we either had gave them
the option of two chocolate things a
variety of juices or a mixture it didn't
really matter but we showed them they
package the goodie bags in front of them
and then we randomly assigned them to
one of two conditions we told people in
the personal spending condition that
this goodie bag was theirs to keep and
it was for them to take home and that
the conclusion of the experiment just a
few minutes from then the other half of
participants we randomly assigned to the
pro social spending condition telling
them that their goodie bag would be
donated to a sick kid at a local
Children's Hospital on their behalf so
not with their name attached to it but
their goodie bag would go directly to a
sick child afterward oh and I should
mention everybody opted to buy the
goodie bag pretty much because we made
it a big pain in the ass if they didn't
want to we told them that you can you
could take the money but if you want the
money the the actual value you have to
pick it up in about three weeks time at
8 o'clock in the morning and so
everybody was like no just get the
goodie bag thing so they did they went
ahead and he bought the goodie bag but
actually giving them that illusion of
choices is a big deal we could talk
about that later if you like so they
felt like they chose to do this kind
deed which i think is pretty important
and after buying the goodie bag we asked
them to report how they were feeling and
what we found was essentially
replicating the same result was that
buying a goodie bag for a sick kid led
people to report higher levels of happy
then had they bought this succeed pretty
much the same exact goodie bag based on
their preference for its contents for
themselves now even further still and I
should note that actually this was true
in both in Canada with our UBC students
and again but then also with the South
African population where on average the
students there actually reported strong
struggles in their household making ends
meet but I was still really intrigued by
this question about pushing how
universal these findings might be to
what extent do we feel the warm glow of
giving not only in rich and poor
countries but actually in places where
you know I wanted to make sure this
wasn't just a North American phenomena
that might you know make its way around
the world something that we we push here
and has made its way to other parts of
the world and so what I did was a couple
years ago I traveled to Vanuatu which is
a country made up of islands in the
middle of the South Pacific my parents
thought it was in Africa so I have to
clarify and I went to this one island
called Tana Islands and to a very small
village called Luna Kovac and the reason
I did this was because it was a
small-scale traditional rural society
that has no electricity no running water
no television no connection with the
Western world and the idea was is that
if I could go as far as possible from
our North American population and
cultural values etc to see whether these
findings still hold there this might be
some strong evidence to suggest that
it's not just North America but this
might be a more fundamental feature of
human behavior and so in this
traditional small-scale society I
recruited as many adults as I could
during my two three-week stay and
actually just to illustrate how far
remove this was from North American life
when I arrived a kid started crying and
I I was terrified not because anyway
they knew I was a doctor but I thought
they would think I was a medical doctor
and this kid had been playing with what
I could see was a machete so I thought
they were gonna call me over and ask me
to help him and I was gonna say all I
have is polysporin like I could anyway
long story short the reason he was
crying was because he'd never seen
anyone as pale as me before and that is
just to illustrate that this was very
far removed from the Western world this
was even during the summer while I was a
few shades slightly darker but still
nothing anything close to the Western
world so all this to say was very very
far removed during my two-three weeks
there
I mean it's a small village society I
recruited 26 adults and essentially
tried to replicate this goodie-bag
paradigm we had done here and in South
Africa so we recruited participants for
what was essentially the equivalent of
half a day's wage there was a hundred
vaatu which is peanuts to us but they
came in they came in two we borrowed
someone's little house which was made up
of sticks and whatnot we we rented it
for the day they came in one at a time
and with me and our research assistant
they sat down they were told that they
had already earned there their finances
for showing up but we also told them
that in addition for filling out the
surveys they got this extra money and we
randomly assign them to one of two
conditions here they were either buying
the they had a choice of candy so they
could pick the candy for themselves or
they could pick the candy for four
others in the village afterward we asked
them to report to the extent they were
feeling for positive emotions because
the other ones that we normally asked
about here didn't have the same cultural
meaning there so they were happy excited
strong and proud and the basic bottom
line was that oh these are extra details
if you like we went through all these
headaches and hassles to really make
sure that this research design was as
close as it could be to what we had done
here wasn't jaded or biased by any of
the local research assistants it was
done in the mother tongue we we
videotaped it back translated it to make
sure everything came across is we
hopefully understood it and there's
leech of my local research assistant
running the experiment in someone's
house long story short was this is just
the I think the only graph I have in my
presentation but this is happiness on
the Y on the y-axis here condition along
the x-axis and the essentially the basic
story is that even people in this small
scale row of society are showing the
emotional rewards of giving and just in
case that isn't convincing enough I've
partnered with some Patrick and one of
our favorite colleagues John Kelly well
basically looking at data from the
Gallup World poll which is the first
representative survey of planet Earth
essentially asked which has asked over
230,000 people in 100
thirty-six countries whether they've
donated money to charity in the past
month and how happy they are and simply
put we find that this relationship
between generous spending and happiness
is positive and eighty-eight percent of
the sample surveyed in fact you can see
these findings in this world map here
where countries shown in green show a
positive relationship between generous
spending countries shown in unhappiness
countries in red shows the reverse and
countries in gray just have no data and
the take-home message is that the world
is generally green suggesting that most
people around the world are people who
donate report higher levels of happiness
around the world all right so these
findings suggests that adults at least
from most countries around the world
might experience these emotional rewards
of giving but I was really intrigued by
not only whether we can see this around
the world but whether we might be able
to see it across the lifespan and so I
partnered with a developmental
psychologist at UBC named Kylie Hamlin
to look at whether some young kids kids
we could interact with might also feel
good when they give but essentially what
we did was we invited kids who were just
under the age of two into the lab one at
a time with their parents and they were
given I mean kids really actually I
should say don't really care too much
about money yet so instead of looking at
financial giving we just looked at food
sharing which I actually think has a lot
to do with our historical origins of
generosity but so kids came into the lab
with their parent and they were taken
through a five phase experiment so in
the first phase they were introduced to
a puppet named monkey who was a stuffed
monkey that they could pet touch and
interact with then each child was given
a windfall of treat so they were eight
edible treats that we specifically
picked treats the kids like a lot so
they were goldfish crackers or teddy
graham crackers then in counterbalanced
order each kid was asked to give either
engage or observe in three critical
steps so the first was they were asked
to watch as the experimenter gave a
treat to monkey oh I should show you I
actually have stills of all that so
that's the child beating monkey this is
the child receiving eight treats then in
one one of the three critical phases the
child watched as the experimenter gave a
treat to monkey
now when monkey received the treat he
appeared to eat it in a very excited
fashion so he would mm-hm and shoved his
face
in the bowl now you can kind of see it
in the bottom of the photo but we
convinced the kids that monkey actually
ate the tree because the the tree the
bull had a false bottom corner it's so
monkey used his nose to push the tree
through the hole and so when he lifted
his face up it looked like he'd eaten
the tree kids were pretty convinced in
fact the video this girl actually goes
he ate it but more interestingly I think
we had two other conditions where two
other phases where the child was
provided by it provided a treat from the
experimenter so what we call non costly
giving because the child has an
opportunity to give but it's not from
their personal treats and asked to give
the treat to monkey monkey responds in
the same excitable fashion shoving his
face by mu and the final key phase I
think is we ask the child to give one of
their own treats to monkey and so rather
than rely on kids actual self reports of
emotion which can be very difficult
under the age of two in fact I first
tried doing that and all kids just that
they were happy all the time so we just
we stopped doing that so we got the idea
to just start videotaping their
experience and then later coding their
their facial expressions for happiness
on a seven-point scale which is actually
not that hard it seems like it takes
like five minutes to train undergraduate
students and they they picked this up
very quickly and so what we found was
coding kids happiness across these five
phases we found two I think important
things first is that kids smiled more
when giving treats away to monkey than
they did when they receive the treats
themselves and it didn't really matter
which whether it was what we called
costly or non costly giving giving their
own treat or an identical treat that
didn't belong to them but what I think
is especially exciting was that kids at
least in this study smiled even like
significantly larger they showed more
positive affect in their faces
interpreted by our coders when they were
giving away their own treat that came at
some personal cost than when giving away
an identical treat that didn't belong to
them to the same puppet who responded in
the exact same way suggesting that
giving might be especially rewarding
when it actually comes with some cost so
this is just on ongoing data collection
but I thought you guys might be
interested to know that one of my
graduate students is really interesting
and trying to find the
under conditions like in which point
this this effect doesn't emerge now that
we've seen it in different ages and in
different places around the world and so
now that I'm at SFU and I there's a very
strong forensic psychology department
I've partnered with some of my
colleagues there that have access to
ex-offender samples and we thought
certainly this might be one place it
would be reasonable that maybe we're not
going to see these emotional rewards of
giving but it's actually in - we've
we've done one study with at risk youth
where we're seeing the same effects and
actually in a large 500% sample of
American ex-offenders we're also still
seeing these emotional rewards of giving
play out in the data so the effect is
not as strong as we're seeing you know
in other samples but it's actually
really interesting that even in samples
you might think that if I'd to have
differing opinions or at least their
behavior bites suggests that they have
less concern for others this seems to be
an emotional reward of giving
essentially what we ask people to do we
did with 500 people online we can't ask
them to buy goodie bags and then tell
them it's gonna go to their local
Children's Hospital because we just
can't make that work but what we ask
people to do was reflect upon a generous
spending example or a time they spend
money on themselves then report how
they're feeling and what we've seen akin
to previous research is that people who
reflect on a time they spent generously
feel happier than people who think about
a time they spent on themselves and so
essentially might take a message to
leave you with today is simply that
giving may promote well-being and it's
not just in people who have a lot to
give but it might even be in folks who
have less and even when it's costly so
thank you
fascinating okay so so if you'll stay up
for a few minutes let's take a few
questions now and then we can come back
later yes and and I didn't get any my
assignment hey your experiments look too
so the immediate happiness after that is
there anything to sort of talk about the
long-term effect people given a lot a
long time ago so none of my studies have
looked at very long term effects I know
of some experiments that have looked at
older samples of like sixty five-plus
that have looked at repeated weeks but
people have had the opportunity to spend
generously over repeated weeks and so
it's not at a very long delay my hunch
is that this this may not last for days
at a time now the good news is though is
what we've seen in some of our past
research and I didn't present here is
that people do feel good after giving
and then that happiness actually leads
them to give again and so what so in a
perfect world you'd be able to get the
encourage someone to give once they'd
feel good and that might continue and
sustain itself for months at a time I'm
a little suspicious that this might last
be on several days at least until you
think about it again like this recall
paradigm I just mentioned seems that
even if you didn't do the action earlier
this morning but you think about it you
still get these benefits so that's a
nice feature but I think the warm glow
of giving of one particular act might
fade away with time but the good news is
is while in that good state people are
inclined to give again and again but no
I don't know of any one particular
paradigm that has looked at the very
long-term consequences and I did truth
be told I might be a little skeptical if
I saw someone do something a month ago
and we're seeing effects you know six
weeks six months down the line so very
fair question yes hi I'm Karen it just
your comment made me reflect on a
conference I attended in an advancement
Northwest conference about three months
ago where they talked about why people
stopped giving in the attrition rates of
giving and and it was based on research
and it was interesting most people
stopped giving to an organization
because they're not made to feel good or
appreciated and so how do you reflect
happiness back onto the person who's
being generous to you so it'd be
interesting to take that particular
study and tucán
generation along with work that the tree
have you been doing mm-hmm I I have done
some other work looking at what factors
make this the these happiness benefits
most readily available like what leads
people to feel good and there are
several things we've realized and I
think this I think actually charities
can put this to good use I hope one is
that people seem to get the largest
emotional rewards of giving when they
get the opportunity to first and
foremost realize that they've had a
positive impact so there are times where
you might give and you don't know where
exactly your dollars are going but I
think to the extent that that's
transparent or people believe that
they've had a straw it's not surprising
but sometimes that doesn't always emerge
and sometimes you can have a negative in
not necessarily in charitable giving but
I always tell this one story my mom but
we're very close with this one family
and I remember we were at the son's
birthday and my mom bought him a clock
and he opened it up and burst into tears
like clearly that wasn't her her
intention she was trying to give a gift
she thought it would make him happy but
there are times where sometimes he can
give and and you missed the mark and I
think that's what happened there and she
didn't feel so good about it he didn't
feel so good about it so not all gifts
are perfect but generally speaking they
think on average most gifts are good and
that's why generally speaking people
feel good about giving so feeling that
you've had a positive impact the extent
to which you have the opportunity to
connect with other people not
surprisingly humans are super super
social species so anytime our good deeds
can lead us to feel connected to other
people that seems to be a big one and
also it seems this isn't my own work but
work of what done by others has
suggested that you actually need to feel
this sense of volition if you feel
forced to do a good deed the emotional
benefits pretty much disappear almost
entirely and that's actually that was
kind of the wrinkle in their process
when I was talking about the goody bags
we had to make people feel that they had
chosen to do it how we just told them
you know you by defaults have now done
this I'm we would have had a much weaker
or if anything null effect and that was
the illusion of choice yeah we're making
earlier yes I need to feel that they've
got that choice okay
and and do some of your research
actually have people see do you study
the effect that they are seeing from
their giving so in the five and twenty
dollars it was it was just it sounded
like giving it was just giving away the
dollars I was supposed to see the impact
they had the
they had the opportunity to spend it as
they like and in many we let people kind
of take those in spending instructions
and run with it so some people bought
like gifts for their siblings many some
people donated to charity but I think
the most popular thing just by the
nature of the timing was taking friends
and family to eat at lunch which later
actually fueled a lot of those questions
looking about the importance of social
connection for experiencing those
emotional rewards okay I think I said
one more hand yeah Brent you bet someone
on the webcast do you have a sense of
how much the costliness of the gift
makes a difference to happiness so if I
just want to happiness maximize can I
just give away very very small amounts
of money and I'll accrue all these
happiness benefits I think there's a
trade-off so I think you need to and I
think that's an interesting point
because some of our data suggests like I
think you need to feel like you've had a
positive impact and giving away you know
a nickel here and there might not lead
you to feel like you've had a
substantial contribution and impact so I
don't know if that will be all that
emotionally rewarding but at the same
time I do think there's the data I
presented here at least with the kids
suggests that costly giving is actually
more beneficial right but I do think
there's a breaking point I think how do
we ask the kids to give away all their
treats they would have thrown a hissy
fit and probably started screaming right
so I think there is a point where you
know giving is rewarding but I also so
while I think people might have a
pro-social instinct I think there's also
the selfish instinct that I'm not
arguing doesn't exist and so I think
it's a delicate balance but I do think
there's no like one dollar amount at
which you hit the sweet spot where you
can feel you've had a positive impact
and and still protect something for
yourself but I and that might vary as a
function of people and their current
situation so but but I do think it is a
delicate interplay between how much can
I give away I think actually costliness
is a sense of like I'm doing this
because I really care but at the same
time you need to feel like you've had an
impact too